we are here today with Teresa gal she is
the co-founder and managing partner of a
crew capital and one of the most
powerful women in Silicon Valley Teresa
thanks so much for having us thanks for
being here so Theresa you sit here as
one of the most powerful women in
Silicon Valley arguably one of the most
powerful women in business but you
didn't start out that way I think your
story is really emblematic of the
American dream and you gave a TED talk
about the American dream and without
going into the Ted Talk what does the
American dream mean to you and your
personal story
it's so Central to my personal story
it's um I really believe I know it
sounds maybe corny these days but I
believe in the fundamental point that
with all of our challenges and uh both
in our as our country but at the end of
the day the American dream still lives
because it lives in people like my
parents and me and my sister and
millions of other immigrants who came to
this country to have to have a chance at
a better life
um and you know I never thought that I
would be here I was born in Jakarta
Indonesia and came with my parents when
I was a young child and ended up growing
up in a town of 2 000 people outside of
Buffalo New York and I never dreamed
that I would even be in Silicon Valley
honestly probably didn't know what it
was but that just goes to show you right
that like
look a lot you also need to have some
luck but someone once told me that you
can improve your chances at luck by
working hard getting a good education
and then really going for something that
you're passionate about and I'm truly
passionate about startups and I've been
fortunate to make a really amazing
career by combining those things
together what did you want to be what
did what did you imagine would be your
career so when I was younger so I've
always liked math and science so maybe
it's not a surprise that I became an
engineer although nowadays I really just
spend time backing other Engineers but
that's fun too but when I was younger I
was really really interested in being an
astronaut Sally Ride was kind of like
you know it before Sally Ride existed I
was all into reading like the right
stuff and fighter pilots but I realized
that while I could maybe I was good at
math and science maybe I could help be
part of the engineering teams to design
those planes or those aircraft I have
terrible ice site and also probably
would never make it through you know
Aviation school and so there you go
let's let's design let's design let's
design aircraft instead of becoming an
astronaut so you went to school for
engineering I did I did
um so I ended up getting a degree in
Material Science and Engineering which
it did a lot of work on uh ceramic
Composites which are actually critical
to spacecraft and aircraft but
particularly because they are highly
resistant to heat and temperature
changes so it's critical for re-entry
from the atmosphere so a little small
part of it but it did there was a
through line from the little girl who
read the right stuff oh I love that how
did you go from that to Silicon Valley
from NASA to Silicon Valley if you will
well I would never even asked from being
an engineer at like General Motors and
British Petroleum working on these you
know new generation materials so as part
of that work my whole family they're all
in medicine uh which was what they
wanted me to do and I had different
ideas so engineering was the next
acceptable career to them so but all I
knew about business was like really big
companies like I said I did an
internship at General Motors I did an
internship at British Petroleum but when
I was so I didn't even know what
startups or Silicon Valley was but I saw
that the people who were engineers that
had the jobs that I thought were more
interesting weren't necessarily the ones
doing like sitting in the lab or behind
the computers doing CAD cam drawings
like what I did as an intern they were
actually the product manager so they
would take that research and then
actually design it into a product and
all of those people also they had
engineering degrees but then they also
had business degrees because they needed
to understand both the consumer demand
side of it as well as like we have to
build products that are safe and
manufacturable So based on that I
decided that I would try to get an MBA
because at that time they all had them
and
um study for my gmats and then out of I
was fortunate to get into a bunch of
schools but
Stanford was my first choice because it
was in the middle of Silicon Valley
again I still didn't know about startups
so I wrote about I'm going to become a
product manager at like Hewlett-Packard
or some you know one of the big
companies that existed back in the 90s
when I went to business school and then
really being here really literally at
the cusp of the internet right at the
early 90s I remember downloading Mosaic
which is what Netscape became in the
computer lab when I was in at business
school at Stanford and that just kind of
opened my eyes to like oh well you can
be a product manager but at a big
company or they're actually these
startups that you know are raising money
from Venture Capital so that's really I
kind of fell into it that way so then I
joined a startup with some classmates
from Stanford we raised some Venture
Capital that's how I learned about the
Venture side of things and then
eventually as they say I I joined the
dark side and became a venture
capitalist and have been doing that ever
since I a side note I think that phrase
is so funny because it's such an
intertwined ecosystem entrepreneurs need
funding yeah investors need something to
fund so I think they're saying it's
intertwined right because it's like the
force right there's the light in the
dark and the Entre In fairness the
entrepreneurs are the light they are the
ones who are the optimists who have to
see the future and then really try to
build it right and we I don't think
we're the dark side but the other side
the yin to their Yang you're right I
agree it's an ecosystem do you remember
your first investment what was the first
company you said that awesome
so the first company that I invested in
So This was 1999.
um and actually it's
um it's interesting because there are
several big companies right now that are
doing this it was uh it was in an
entrepreneur that I had worked with
before
and he had an idea to build sort of
Internet software that would allow
people to make real-time credit
decisions in order to extend credit
whether that be e-commerce companies or
you know businesses to other small
businesses you can think of it in some
ways essentially and they started out a
little bit around the same time so and
this company still exists it's a company
called bill.com it's not that different
from what bill.com does today but in the
whole full circle so that was you know
not 1999 that company ended up getting
acquired by somebody else so it wasn't
you know it wasn't us you know a huge
success
um but interestingly in full circle
bill.com bought one of our Port one of
our acrew portfolio companies last year
so it's just kind of really interesting
how the the lines connect somehow that's
incredible all right let's talk I love
full circle moments and I wanted to talk
to you about a crew you founded acrew in
2019 you were 51 years old and you very
quickly or maybe it was it seemed quick
to the press it probably didn't feel
quick to you I think your first fund was
250 million dollar debut fund
talk to me about how and why you started
this yeah so you know I guess the
biggest thing I would say is looking
back co-founding a crew with my partners
was the best career decision I've ever
made hands down and I know that you know
maybe particularly in these times but
kind of always right like the idea of
going out on your own and leaving your
firm whether that's a venture capital
firm or a big company and starting
something on your own can seem really
scary but now with the benefit of
hindsight I feel like it's actually the
smartest thing you can do is to bet on
yourself because as managers right we we
choose people you know to hire to
promote
um and or also as investors like you
know whether it's projects or companies
to fund and we do it in large part
especially at the early stage on the
people like you know do I believe you
are going to be the Right leader for
this business and
calculated risk is what investments
about risk reward who do you know better
than yourself and so betting on yourself
sounds scary but it's actually probably
the most informed bet you'll ever make
on a management team who can you know
better than yourself you make it sound
so easy
[Laughter]
my mind is fun you
choir is a good deal of self-assurance
so I will say I am very fortunate in a
couple of ways right so I didn't always
have this self-confidence but sometimes
sometimes things happen in your career
that seem like they're a big
disappointment and you you find yourself
being braver to and having more
self-confidence to try something new
because the path you thought you had in
front of you isn't exactly what you
thought it would be
um so I'll be honest that was part of it
I'm not sure I would have done it except
that there were some disappointments
that led me to sort of rethink
what I wanted to do
I know that I was very lucky that I was
able to do this both from the standpoint
of being at a stage in my career where I
had the resources to like take a chance
on myself and that I have amazing
support from my family and my partners
to do all of these things so I I want
people to think it's easy but I also
want people to understand like I
understand like I'm very
I have I understand the pragmatic part
of it too and a lot of things have to be
in place
so with that said I think that you know
it's been
it's turned out to be the greatest thing
um you mentioned the debut fund we've
been fortunate a crew Capital now has we
have over a billion dollars under
management we launched a crew diversify
Capital fund which is the largest
Venture fund focused on increasing
diversity of stock ownership in Tech
startups and bringing those people into
the wealth generation and onto the
boards of these companies so I'm really
excited to be able to bring together my
professional passion with my personal
passion for better diversity inclusion
in Tech so I'm super excited and I feel
fortunate I also think the other big
thing is as working moms we convince
ourselves that we need to take the safer
path professionally in order to be more
stable for our families and
notwithstanding everybody's personal
circumstances are different
understanding I was fortunate from that
perspective I have actually found that I
am able to be much more involved and
engaged in my children's lives while
also being as excited and probably you
know knock wood as
you know my career has actually taken
off so both things have really taken off
my my relationship with my kids my
ability you know because part of it is
when you're the boss whether it's a
venture firm or your own you know your
own business of whatever sort I'm pretty
sure my partners would say I work just
as hard if not harder than I did before
but the difference is I control the
timing and the agenda so and I think I
think everybody on the a crew team
really appreciates this so we have a
thing right which is like I learned
pretty early in my career that if we
give people the flexibility to like you
know hey we understand it's important to
show up at your kids soccer game or you
know if your kid gets sick then of
course you drop everything and go to the
doctor or your parent or whatever
when you give people that flexibility I
found that people actually work harder
and feel much more aligned and committed
to the place where they work you hit on
a lot of really important points in what
you just said I want to start with the
learning moments and I want to ask the
question this way was there a moment
before starting a crew that you were
looking at your career and you thought I
can't do this I need to give up it's too
hard juggling family juggling personal
goals juggling this important work and
if so what was that moment there was so
um I talked about this some so there was
a point where I was having
um
some challenges both at work and it also
coincided with my divorce from my kid's
dad so as you can imagine that's a lot
of change going on at the same time
and I thought about you know I had been
really fortunate that I was in a
position where if uh if I didn't work
again I my family would be fine and I
could be there you know 100 for my kids
should I just give up venture capital
but I realized a couple of things one
was that the setbacks in the career
weren't really related to investing or
working with the companies it had more
to do with the culture of the
partnership Dynamic and I was like well
you know what I have a pretty clear idea
of like what I would like that culture
to be
and I still love working with my
companies and I still love meeting new
companies and potentially investing in
them
and I think actually the biggest thing
was that I realized during that time
that I could
be there for my kids my kids were very
young men so I could do like Nursery
School drop off and pick up or you know
um
volunteer to be a field trip chaperone
for my older kid and I could do all of
those things and still do what I loved
and I actually think probably not the
little one but the older one was kind of
like you know what Mom you're like it's
better like you know because they they
were getting the big kids are far apart
made as you know so the one that was
older was like nine it was kind of like
it's really great that you're starting
to come to like the field trips and
stuff but like yeah you don't need to be
here all the time so I was like okay
this is a good balance it's like you
know so just make yourself available in
the moments when they want you and now
that they're teenagers now I really
understand it's like being around but
not being around someone they want you
so it's a long answer but the short
answer is so you know I had this like I
had this Epiphany where it was like like
obviously going through a really hard
time with for our family I'm happy to
say we're all like a big beautiful
Modern Family blended family now but um
part of it was like the Insight from one
of my kids and part of it was just like
in talking with many of the
entrepreneurs I was fortunate enough to
work with they were like look we haven't
seen any change because I was like you
know look I'm gonna have to be a little
bit bit like you know context switching
not not always as available for these
next few months while we figure out the
new schedule and everything else and you
know to hear one of them say like look
we've known you for a long time and you
they seem happier than ever despite I
don't even know what's going on because
you're like and you're just still there
for us right and to have your kids say
the same things so then I was like okay
maybe I can do this there's no like I'm
still young there's no need to like give
it all up and maybe I think in the long
run it was probably better for my kids
because I'm I I don't think I am but I
could see how if I was it was like to
take to put the career in a box and then
just focus on the kids I could see how I
could have become a helicopter Mom I
know that about myself treat your kids
like a portfolio company maybe like oh
no thank you well it's actually why the
portfolio companies don't want you to
just have one right like it's good to
have like five or six because it's like
if you just focused on them all the time
it's like a little too much
so it sounds to me and I've talked to a
lot of powerful women about what were
the conditions that allowed them to rise
to their position it sounds like you're
describing a support system but I don't
want to put words in your mouth how
would you describe the conditions that
allowed you to sit in a seat that you
sit today yeah absolutely so look it
definitely started kind of going back to
the question about my family and
emigrating here in the importance
definitely starts with my family and the
support of my family early on and and
sort of telling me that look you if you
you know school is really important work
really hard be very serious about that
but also even later in life like my my
parents I'm my parents live half a mile
away from here and especially when my
kids were young and even now even
yesterday
um when I had to be in two places at
once you know to help with everything
from like helping kids pick and and it's
not
it's important because frankly now that
I have one that's older I see how strong
the relationship is that they have with
their grandparents and so it's a
wonderful thing not only does it
alleviate mommy guilt if you can't be
two places at once but it's really
wonderful to see the relationship
multi-generational relationship amongst
the family so it definitely starts with
that you know I do think I don't know
whether it's education but like a love
of learning right like the thing I love
and why I went to the dark side right is
I get to work with five or six companies
at a time all building different
Technologies different stages of their
growth different business models and I
get to meet dozens of new companies
every month and so if you really like
learning about new things around
business and technology so I think it's
like having built creating the right
support system around yourself
and then frankly I used to give young
girl Executives like find something that
you're really passionate about because
look if you're I used to give this talk
to a lot of like young in their career
people right it's like look you've
already you know you've done school
maybe grad school you're clearly like
you've got the raw materials to be great
find something that you really love
because if you really love it then the
chances that you'll be not just good but
great increases and at the same time and
maybe this goes to like take a chance on
yourself if at any point in time you're
not loving and I don't mean every day
obviously no one loves their job every
minute of every day but if for a long
period of time you don't love what
you're doing don't be afraid to change
and do something else because it just
increases the chances that you'll be
great at it because it doesn't feel I
mean it's obviously work but doesn't
feel as much like work if you're getting
enjoyment from it now we are sitting
here today for the 50 over 50 franchise
which celebrates and highlights women
who are stepping into their power over
the age of 50 and Beyond did you ever
imagine your career when you were say a
teen did you ever think when I'm 60
years old I'm going to be doing this
what did you picture
um so I definitely didn't picture this
like I said I didn't even when I was a
teen I didn't even know really anything
about Silicon Valley and I didn't I
probably didn't even know how to spell
venture capital right so not this for
sure honestly when I was a teen I would
have thought being in my 50s I was like
very old I would not have thought
that
much
um so I don't know I don't know maybe I
maybe I thought that I'd be like you
know an engineer somewhere and but
getting close to retirement and honestly
like now I feel like
um
I feel like there's still so much ahead
do you feel like being over 50 is an
advantage or disadvantage in your line
of work so I think the answer is
contextual so sometimes it's an
advantage and sometimes it's a
disadvantage a lot of times so you know
we we back exciting new entrepreneurs
and in many place in many types of
companies as I'm sure you've read about
many people are starting their companies
very young so when I started adventure
and I was more their age peers now it's
very different so I think you can be a
disadvantage from the standpoint of the
next great 20-something entrepreneur is
not necessarily going to be found by me
but that's why it helps to have a
partnership that truly like we we're
fortunate we have three generations so
that partner is probably going to be
found by my 20-something year old
partner I'm the where it can be an
advantage though is what you talked
about before in terms of the fundraising
right so like our investors who are you
know University endowments family
offices they tend to appreciate people
who have a long track record who they
can see you know investing and returning
money to their investors in both good
cycles and bad Cycles so now I have the
Fortuner good for good or bad fortune of
you know having started my career in the
crazy 99 2000 and then down through 2003
and then also
um obviously 2008-2009 and now the
current environment so it depends on the
context I think with certain people who
you work with in Venture it's an
advantage and with others it's not and
then even in working with the companies
you know being on the board like it's
just it is an advantage to have seen you
know have been through 10 m a
transactions and you know literally
hundreds of follow-on financing and so
in that case you know now I've kind of
like grown into I can be the the Elder
Statesman if you will on the board who
can you know that that the entrepreneurs
will turn to like okay especially now
how do we think about what to do when
the macro environment is changing not in
a good way for us so rapidly how do we
think about this and find the right
balance of you know uh conservative cash
but still going after the opportunities
for new technologies and growth that we
see so I would say on balance I choose
to think of it more as an advantage and
in the places where it's a disadvantage
I think that's why you have part
partners and colleagues and you find you
know you fill in for each other's
strengths and weaknesses that's a
healthy perspective we had someone last
year for this package tell us that she
was told Venture is a Young Person's
game why are you trying to start your
own firm but it sounds like you've had a
different experience and one that allows
you to layer your experience on top of
your teams yeah I and look I had those
same questions asked of me
when I started my when I when I went out
and started my first fun at the ripe old
age of still in my 40s
um so I am I'm aware of that and so
again I think it's I think it is very
much around it's building a partnership
and you build the right partnership just
like some of my partners are really
really amazing at investing in fintech
companies and I do a lot of cyber
security like just like in that same way
there's other things you know so it's
about building it's like building a team
I'm a big I'm a big sports fan so the
analogy and I'm a big I'm a big Warriors
fan so the analogy is like you know you
don't want five players who are all
seven feet tall and play center you
still need a point guard to bring the
ball up you know you literally need like
people who complement each other you
just alluded to sometimes being the
Elder Statesman in the room to put on
that hat as you look at women and
they're who are just starting their
career in their 20s or maybe in their
30s and are experiencing burnout we have
seen record rates of burnout through the
pandemic and pressures on women
uncertain economic environment doesn't
help the situation what's your advice
for women let's start broad just any in
any sector in any career right now who
might be thinking
I'd do it I need to take a sabbatical or
I need to make a change or this is just
feeling too hard what do you say to them
first of all I would say I think that
this has been a very hard environment
for a lot of people and I hope that the
through things like good reporting like
yours and elsewhere people are at least
more aware of the unique and I'll call
them extra challenges that working moms
have not that the environment hasn't
been challenging for everybody and my
advice would be if you feel like your
current situation isn't sustainable for
yourself
you know find a place that does sustain
you and can still work with your life
your family as well as your work now
that might be starting something
yourself which could be like you know
going freelance instead of working for
so you can have more control of your
hours or frankly these days just finding
a company many many of the companies now
allow people to work flexible hours
hours from home so now that's assuming
you love what you do if you don't love
what you do then maybe think about what
do you love doing and maybe that is like
a complete career change because we've
been reading about people who do that
too and you brought up sabbatical like
I'm a Believer in sabbaticals I took a
sabbatical when I made my decision to
leave my big firm and start my own thing
so I'm all for sabbaticals I think that
if you're fortunate enough to have one
from your company you should take
advantage of it and if if you don't then
you can make your own I just changing
things so it's really hard to think
about what you want to do when you're in
it like 24 7. so whether that's like
a couple week vacation or an actual
sabbatical depending on what your
personal circumstances are I highly
recommend it gives you a lot more
clarity on like what's really important
and what do you really like but I would
just say
I'm kind of trying to be an optimist
right like so if I take like lemonade
out of lemons
think that so many companies are aware
of this and look they've had to make
some adaptations I think there are a lot
more options that are a lot more
flexible I think very few jobs require
like 40 hours a week during set hours in
a specific location away from your
family and your other responsibilities
if you're in one of those then I think
there are plenty of other interesting
both companies and and careers that are
a lot more open
and what's your advice specifically for
entrepreneurs in this uncertain economic
environment I know there's a lot of a
lot of nerves out there for lack of a
better word yeah so the advice that I
give the entrepreneurs that I'm
fortunate enough to work with is the
following which is so we
we don't control the macroeconomic
environment we never have so
have a lens and understanding of what's
happening in the macro which for
entrepreneurs right now it's really hard
to raise money so I don't know when
that's going to get better but I don't
think it's going to be any time real
soon so then you should think about well
the money that you have today
what's the best way that you can invest
it whether that's if you're far enough
along becoming profitable so that you
have control of your own destiny as I
say you'll decide if and when you ever
raise more money or if that's not
possible finding that right balance of
you know conserving your cash to have it
last as long as possible so you can grow
you know the point is still to grow or
meet your Milestones but it's it's a
different view right whereas like last
year was sort of like growth at all
costs right now different environment
okay what have you what resources do you
have today and what's the most you can
get to with what you've got today it
will get better even in 2000 because I
lived through it it does get better it
might be a couple of years but it'll get
better how does right now feel compared
to 2008 or 2000.
so to me it feels for Tech anyway for
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley
I'm afraid I think it feels a little bit
more like 2000 than 2008. so 2008 was
obviously a really significant
macroeconomic shock the Great Recession
um but for Tech a lot of it was focused
around
Financial Services Banking and real
estate so the return to normalcy for
Capital raising and just growth for tech
companies in Silicon Valley came back
pretty quickly in a couple of quarters
whereas in 2000 we were the epicenter
and some might say we are again and so
huge run up in 99 huge crash in early
2000 and it was probably a good two or
three years before the capital started
flowing back to Tech startups
now realizing the run-up wasn't quite as
severe as fast as it was in 99 versus
now so I think we're going to be
somewhere in the middle
um
meaning I think it's going to be hard to
raise money like we've seen there's very
few IPOs for example
um
for this year and I personally think
most of next year so maybe it'll be
about a year and a half or two years
instead of three years
um but we on the other hand the reason
for optimism
especially for companies that are in
Tech that are earlier stage is that the
size and scale of the market opportunity
is so much larger I think when
when Netscape went public in 1996 there
the total number of Internet like people
who who had access to Internet through
browsers or computers back then internet
through dial up whatever else was
measured in the sort of 60 to 70 million
in the whole world and in 2020 I think
the number because many people have
multiple devices I'm sure you do I know
I do it was something like 5 billion wow
so if you just think about the scale and
that's not even talking about the
fundamental technology scale right so
cloud computing
machine learning and artificial like the
technology advances so I'm medium to
long term super optimistic because the
the like technology now every company I
think is a technology company you read
about even like car companies now our
technology companies which on the bad
side we found out that was true right
with the supply chain crisis and like
when they didn't have semiconductors so
technology is just much more integrated
into so many parts of the US and global
economy so that's why I'm medium to long
term super excited about you know being
fortunate to be a tech investor here in
Silicon Valley in the short term I think
that it's going to be it's going to
continue to be hard to raise money right
the FED keeps raising interest rate just
cap you know capital is getting Tighter
by Design and I don't know well I'm not
an expert on that I don't know when
that's going to get better but I think
the com people who are building real
businesses you know the last couple of
downturns you talked about 2008 2009
some great companies have come out of
those downturns and I think that
um
this this current downturn will be the
same
so medium to long-term optimistic for
Tech investors what about for women
we've seen I've covered the funding
statistics year over year over year and
you see a little bit of progress a
little bit of pullback it feels a little
bit like two steps forward one step back
what's your outlook for women right now
A medium-term excited I guess I've been
I've been following those statistics
long enough to see that it's made some
meaningful improvements you're right not
in the last couple of years but I go
back to like 2000 so when at least in
terms of the percentage of female
Founders as a percentage of companies
receiving some Venture Capital backing
that number has like doubled the dollars
have been stubbornly small and it's
still only about two percent but the
reason why I'm bullish even in the
shorter term right two things one is
when I talk to younger female
entrepreneurs
it's a very different mindset than you
know even 10 years ago meaning they
understand the challenges but they are
much more undaunted and also see it as a
potential area of strength great
networks like all raising there there
are there are networks to support one
another and move things forward that's
one
um and two I'm excited because as more
women become successful Executives and
entrepreneurs they start investing
either as an angel investor or as an
investor in Venture funds like mine and
others right and so The Virtuous cycle
starts to build like it's long been held
like people say it's a voice it's true
right like there's a reason why people
have written a lot about the PayPal
Mafia and read it's amazing a lot like
but there's also a reason why like how
have they been so successful well PayPal
was really successful a bunch of them
leave to go stutter the things they ask
their friends to invest in their
companies and there's there's nothing
nefarious about it just becomes a
self-reinforcing network why excited
because I think we finally have some
really amazing self-reinforcing networks
of women on entrepreneurs and investors
so the flywheel is beginning I know
you've talked about being often the only
woman in the room particularly earlier
in your career and I know that's often
framed as a negative thing a very lonely
thing and it can feel very lonely but I
am wondering were there ever moments
that you felt like it was a Competitive
Edge
well you know I tried to early in my
career because that was the reality all
throughout my 20s and 30s I realized
that it can be positive in a campaign
Edge so I realized that for example in
at conferences or trade shows or even
during a fundraising process once I
realized that I might be the only woman
that that entrepreneur or that
entrepreneurial team might meet the
entire day at a conference with 30 000
people
and that they might be fundraising and
going to dozens of venture capital firms
and I would might be the only woman that
they would meet in that process
the way I thought of it in my own mind
anyway as a potential Advantage was well
if I can make a good connection with
them by asking them a smart question or
making a smart comment about their if it
was at a conference like about their
about their trade their demonstration or
in a in a pitch meeting about their
business that when I wanted to follow up
with them and I sent them an email
since I have a female presenting name
the chances that they would remember who
I was out of the 50 or 100 people that
they had met was actually higher so I
was like because when you especially
earlier when you're like you know
there's there's dozens of young
Associates trying to find like the hot
company and like make that impression I
was like okay if I can make a moderately
positive to positive impression I'm more
likely to be remembered than someone who
makes a similarly positive impression
because we're all wearing the same
uniforms and everybody had the same
first name like I worked at a firm with
like more guys named Jim Joe and John
than females
um true fact uh that that was my
advantage that's what I told myself was
going to be my advantage instead of
being focused on the fact that I was
going to be the only woman in the room
or the only woman they might meet in
their entire fundraising process I like
that early in my career I was a personal
finance and markets reporter so found
myself in various rooms on Wall Street
it was very self-conscious if I'm the
only person in the room who's wearing
red or the only woman in the room and
then I'm also wearing red on top of it
so I felt like I really stood out and I
think it made me shrink back in moments
but it sounds like you really leaned
into it I leaned into it from that
perspective but it's funny you talked
about the way you dress because in the
90s 2000s you know the VC uniform back
then used to be light blue button-down
and some sort of khaki pants now it's
like jeans and a hoodie because we want
to look like the entrepreneurs but
anyway so I never wore dresses I
literally like copied the uniform
because I didn't want to I was like I'm
obviously gonna stand out as the only
one in the room so I'm at least gonna
like try to look like look the part I
should look like a VC so I should dress
like the other VCS that's so interesting
well now other VCS can dress like you
yeah it was a long time until I felt
like I could dress like myself and my
work wardrobe and my real wardrobe I
think that's been an evolution for a lot
of women yeah I have to say I think so
too what do you wish someone had told
you about aging or being over 50 that
you know now that you didn't know when
you were younger
one is
that I wish someone would have told me
that
um
so on the positive and negative so on on
the
on the on the positive I wish someone
would have told me that just being more
comfortable in who you are
um would give you a kind of
confidence and self-understanding that
would actually help you in your career
as well
um and on the not so positive
um I wish someone would have told me
that
um as you get older the gray hair needs
to be dyed more frequently
it's a lot of work because I think it's
still true that right like when if men
go salt and pepper they're perceived as
being you know you know more serious
more more gravitas
um and I do think in this
you know to your prior question about
like is it an advantage disadvantage in
Venture and in Tech to be older I think
in that case it can be a disadvantage to
be perceived as older particularly if
you're a female well Teresa thank you so
much thank you for having me it was so
fun
[Music]